-Our first guest tonight
is one of the biggest
movie stars in the world.
She's starring in the new movie
"Sing 2,"
which is in theaters
Wednesday, December 22nd.
Please welcome
Scarlett Johansson!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes, that's what I'm
talking about!
Come on now! Yeah!
Ah!
Scarlett,
I'm so happy to see you.
Welcome back to the show.
-Thank you.
It's great to be here.
-Yeah.
-To be here.
-I did get to see you
in person recently
at the Kennedy Center Honors.
-That's right, the Kennedy
Center Honors in D.C.
That was a couple of weeks ago
now
and was, I think, the latest
I've been up in about,
I would say, 2 1/2 years.
-[ Laughs ] Is that right?
Because of the baby?
-Yeah.
-How is the new baby?
How's everything going?
-So far, so good.
-Yeah.
How do you like having two kids
at home?
How does your older daughter
feel?
-My daughter, Rose, is 7,
so she's in second grade.
-Cute.
-She has a lot going on
in her life.
She's got a very active
social calendar.
[ Laughter ]
So she's not -- Yeah.
She's not as interested in
the baby as --
-I don't know. Let's say, like,
any other thing, really.
-Yeah.
-Is she at the age where she's
embarrassed by you or not yet?
-Yeah, she's embarrassed by me
because I do a little dance
when the school bus pulls up.
[ Laughter ]
And she doesn't like that.
-"Don't do that, Mom, please.
Why do you have to be --" Yeah.
-Yeah, she doesn't like that.
So, of course,
and then I just do it --
I exaggerate it even further.
She's at a phase right now
where she keeps telling me
that I can't tell her
what to do.
[ Laughter ]
Which to me, I'm like...
I'm not going to argue with her
about it.
-Of course not.
But you're like,
"Of course I can tell you
what to do."
Yeah. "You're a child.
You're a baby."
-That seems like a conversation
that's not going anywhere good.
-I want to talk to you
about "Sing 2."
You're very funny in the movie,
but I also --
I heard that you do
a Cher impression.
Is that true?
-Yeah.
I do a Cher impression.
Yeah, I do. I do.
I haven't broken it out
in a while.
I don't think I've broken it out
since I got my tonsils removed.
-Was it -- Is it --
"Do you believe?"
What's your impression?
What song do you do?
-[ Clears throat ]
♪ What am I suppo-- ♪
I don't know.
[ as Cher ] ♪ Sit around
and wait for you ♪
♪ Well, I can't do that ♪
♪ No turning back ♪
-No way! Oh, my God!
Hey, that was it!
-[ Normal voice ]
That's not bad.
-♪ No turning back ♪
Oh, my God, that was a good one.
Do you do karaoke?
I guess no one --
No one really does it.
-I did karaoke
for my recent birthday, yeah.
I did karaoke
for my recent birthday.
I hadn't done it in so long
and -- Yeah, it was everything.
-What's your go-to song?
-Um...
My go-to song...
I mean, I like to kind of --
I like to tease the crowd.
So first I like to start off
with something a little bit
sort of, like, a little kind of
intimate, emotional.
I'd go with, like,
a Fleetwood Mac song actually.
-Ooh.
-And then -- But, like,
one of the more -- you know,
like, maybe "Landslide"
so people are like, "Whoa!"
Kind of everybody is
in the room now.
[ Laughter ]
Then I like to kind of --
I like to ramp it up
a little bit
and then I'll do
a Billy Joel song
like when we're maybe
three tequila shots in.
-Yep, that's very smart.
[ Laughter ]
This is all good.
-And then after that, I like to
bring the group together
and everybody,
I like to join --
everybody join in
for a rendition of
"Bohemian Rhapsody."
-That's exactly the right way
to do it.
See? You're a pro.
You know exactly what's up.
-I know.
-In the movie,
Ash gets to meet her hero.
Was there ever a moment
in your life where you're like,
"I'm nervous to meet
this person,"
and then it turned out to be
actually awesome and relaxing?
-Yeah. I met Judge Judy once.
And...
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-I was in a restaurant
and I saw Judge Judy at a table
with her family.
And I -- Oh, my God.
I was so star-struck.
I couldn't believe it.
-Yeah.
Were you afraid a little bit
that she might
judge you or say something?
-Like, judge me?
[ Laughter ]
-Yes, of course.
It's what she does for a living.
Yeah.
I'd be afraid.
-Yeah, I was a little nervous.
I didn't know if she was going
to, you know --
I mean, she's like --
she's like an icon, obviously.
-Yeah, of course.
-And so, I don't know.
I didn't know if she was going
to look at me and be like,
"Get away from my table.
I'm here with my family."
And, like, you know.
-"Zip it."
-"I'm Judge Judy.
Leave me alone."
-Yeah, exactly.
-She wasn't like that. No.
She was wonderful,
and I was so relieved
that she was a very nice person
and she probably was like --
Also, I think she was surprised
that I was there and I was --
Oh, I was very geeked out.
-Yeah.
-I mean, I grew up with
Judge Judy.
-Me too. We all did.
-Yeah, she's amazing.
-She's the greatest.
But she was very, very nice.
-Well, once you meet her, then
you go, "Yeah, everyone else
should be cake,"
and that's how you get to do --
get to sing a song with Bono.
You're like, "Oh, yeah. Please.
I already met Judge Judy.
Bono is --"
[ Laughter ]
-I would love to do a duet
with Judge Judy.
[ Laughter ]
-"Sing 3."
Let's make it happen.
[ Laughter ]
Can you tell everyone
what's happening in "Sing 2"?
-What is happening in "Sing 2"?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I will tell you
what's happening in "Sing 2."
You guys are trying to go to
this giant casino.
You're taking the show to, like,
a giant -- basically Vegas.
A version of Vegas.
-Great. And then what?
[ Laughter ]
Then what happens?
-Then you meet Bobby Cannavale's
character, who's Jimmy Crystal.
And he's like --
-I love Bobby Cannavale.
-Well, he's in the movie.
[ Laughter ]
-Cool!
-Yeah, you're going to
freak out.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God! He's the best.
-But do they pull it off?
Do they not pull it off?
I mean, it's -- it's --
-Do they?
-The stakes are higher.
The stakes are higher.
And you have Scarlett Johansson
and you have Bono,
ladies and gentlemen.
What more could you ask for?
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Scarlett Johansson
singing with Bono in "Sing 2."
Take a look at this.
-♪ You broke the bonds ♪
♪ And you loosed the chains ♪
♪ You carried the cross ♪
♪ Of my shame ♪
♪ You know I believe it ♪
♪ But I still haven't found
what I'm looking for ♪
[ Cheers and Applause ]
-I mean, how cute is that?
Hedgehog, it's so cute!
Scarlett Johansson, everybody.
-Porcupine! Porcupine!
-"Sing 2" is in theaters
December 22nd.